[SPEAKER_00]: Second Whale Sun, probably around 2 p.m. in the afternoon, Gouge and Paul discuss their next steps.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so, I mean, I'm thinking that we need a lead on, well, we're not going to get a lead on Khaleesi right away, but who the hell is selling those masks?
[SPEAKER_02]: You know what that mask is, correct?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I get it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, you didn't just pick it because it looks cool, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I kind of did.
[SPEAKER_01]: You did?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it's comfortable.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a lot more comfortable than...
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, did you hear what that guy said in there?
[SPEAKER_02]: He said that there were, like, assassins wearing masks like that?
[SPEAKER_02]: He said that that's what the word kind of was?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't even know.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's the problem?
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, keep the mask.
[SPEAKER_02]: It may come in handy later.
[SPEAKER_02]: I wouldn't wear it for your day-to-day shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because one of my guys might knife you in the future.
[SPEAKER_01]: Why might one of your guys might make me in the future?
[SPEAKER_02]: You're wearing a mask from the Scarlet Brotherhood.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which boggles the mind that somebody would sell it in the marketplace?
[SPEAKER_02]: Unless that was maybe a key for...
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Was it on display, like right above the place, or did you have to actually ask for it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you remember you sell the one mask?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and then you asked for a darker tone, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you had to say something to ask for that mask?
[SPEAKER_01]: Just ask for a darker tone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Was it the same mask?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, it was the same exact mask, just in a darker tone.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was a little different, but yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or my mask.
[SPEAKER_01]: The other mask was in a lighter tone.
[SPEAKER_02]: God, it couldn't be that simple.
[SPEAKER_02]: You just stumbled across a password.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you want one, you can have one.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, did I stumble across a password?
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know, but maybe.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want a darker tone.
[SPEAKER_02]: That mask belongs to the Scarlet Brotherhood, which is not exact.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, they're not actually open.
[SPEAKER_02]: They don't have temples around, do they?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Last time I ran into those shitbags.
[SPEAKER_02]: I had to kill a fucking couple of them, and they did some really unpleasant shit to me in return.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not one of them.
[SPEAKER_02]: So sorry if it's a little triggery.
[SPEAKER_02]: You just wanted a darker version.
[SPEAKER_01]: I did.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, so that guy, I'm not saying, you came with Jameis and Prince Gian.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm just saying, wherever you got that mask, I think we need to backtrack.
[SPEAKER_02]: That fucker needs to visit your dungeon.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm serious.
[SPEAKER_01]: I- I got all sorts of people that I think- Look, I'm sure you have some serious connections with some people.
[SPEAKER_01]: For me, this has little of interest to it, and I do not see where finding where this mask came from- You don't see it connected to anything?
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are the Scarlet Brothers the Tali?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are they the what?
[SPEAKER_01]: The Toli.
[SPEAKER_01]: The Toli Rats.
[SPEAKER_01]: No.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then what?
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a pointless objective that we have not been given.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're beyond the Toli Rats in priority hire.
[SPEAKER_02]: They would be who the Toli Rats could be working for.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: What?
[SPEAKER_01]: Where do we get?
[SPEAKER_01]: Where do you get that off?
[SPEAKER_02]: I just told you that I fought one.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're going to challenge me now?
[SPEAKER_02]: Just because you fight one doesn't mean- You don't know anything about me.
[SPEAKER_02]: You've probably grown up at Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've probably never left.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I have.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't want to know why, Dad?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or Jude?
[SPEAKER_01]: You wanna know why, Jude?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because I'm doing the missions that I've been given.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, I've had a lifetime of missions.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: That have taken me outside of Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you would like to ask Gion about this and if it should be supported in his aid or even time, then let's go do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: What is your problem with taking my lead in the fact that we need to abduct, possibly torture, certainly threaten- We are going off of no evidence.
[SPEAKER_01]: We are going off of no evidence of this that is related to our- You care about evidence?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I care about evidence.
[SPEAKER_01]: I see this as a complete waste of time.
[SPEAKER_02]: This is spy versus spy.
[SPEAKER_02]: You care about evidence.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, like, we need to know that we got the right guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's why I said we'll torture him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, maybe, like, before we torture him, we'll try to do some other stuff first.
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you seriously... You've got a problem.
[SPEAKER_02]: What does this have to do with finding the top?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm telling you...
[SPEAKER_02]: That mask means something significant.
[SPEAKER_01]: Even if you didn't know what it was.
[SPEAKER_01]: It could be related to the demonic demons from hell.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: It is not our mission or our problem.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have not been assigned that.
[SPEAKER_02]: It is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: You know what?
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's take this to James.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's apparently your godfather.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fine.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll take it to James.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: We'll see what he says then.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: See what Janus is done with his council meeting?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, it's been a couple hours, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: So whoever it was that gave us wine and cheese or if there's a little old lady that's like...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I can take two.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: So... Oh, you can.
[SPEAKER_00]: They walk away.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And you guys sit there glowering at each other about this for a little bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Five minutes later, however, the door opens and Lord Jameis comes into the room and basically says, oh, I see you've already gone through the refreshments, Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: Please bring more wine and more cheese for Jude.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's good wine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, I know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is your character overweight?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm being serious.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, he's an elf.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's not.
[SPEAKER_00]: He says, I know that Paul
[SPEAKER_00]: Rarely pertains about Paul.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, that's fine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: In short, we have a lead that Paul doesn't think is significant.
[SPEAKER_02]: I do.
[SPEAKER_02]: The lead is that Paul got that mask that he's... You're still wearing a mask.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: You never take it off.
[SPEAKER_02]: Does he even eat?
[SPEAKER_02]: What do you do?
[SPEAKER_02]: Shove it through like a little opening?
[SPEAKER_02]: Shut the fuck up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anyways...
[SPEAKER_02]: That mass belongs to the Scarlet Brotherhood, which is a Suli organization down on the southern islands beyond the Toli.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know that we're kind of investigating the Toli, but we've talked about potential higher than the Toli.
[SPEAKER_02]: The Tolis are greedy idiots.
[SPEAKER_02]: I want to abduct the person in the square that sold him that.
[SPEAKER_02]: When we were talking to, we discovered that one of the people was part of the...
[SPEAKER_00]: The Scarlet Brotherhood is going to be investigated by somebody else, not you.
[SPEAKER_02]: You didn't tell me that.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, Paul, he is correct.
[SPEAKER_00]: That mask is not something you should be wearing in public, or at all.
[SPEAKER_02]: Keep it, by all means, in case we have to use it in the future, but I don't think you should be walking around with that thing on.
[SPEAKER_01]: You give me a nice lookin' mask and you take it away from me like that.
[SPEAKER_01]: What, did he give it to you?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, I'm asking as a deal, a deal.
[SPEAKER_01]: How would you do something like that?
[SPEAKER_02]: Look, I don't care how badass it is, dude.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can, like, make something more.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can't make something more.
[SPEAKER_02]: Get it made!
[SPEAKER_02]: You know what I mean?
[SPEAKER_00]: I see you've become acquainted with yourselves.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, please bring me up to speed on what the two of you have ascertained.
[SPEAKER_02]: So investigating the person that made the attempt on his life.
[SPEAKER_02]: Begged ignorance.
[SPEAKER_02]: He has the markings of, I describe the markings.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I say, I recognize that as being part of the thieves' guild.
[SPEAKER_02]: He said that somebody named Janus, probably a surname, of course, had been in charge for about eight months.
[SPEAKER_02]: I asked him to investigate Janus for any potential connection.
[SPEAKER_02]: He said that it was common knowledge on the street of Toli assassins, but that they had left five days ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: They've left the city?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which seems a little weird that all of them... Well, it seems a little foreboding.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he also...
[SPEAKER_01]: He said that this happened five to seven days ago.
[SPEAKER_02]: I asked him if there were any agents that had been left and he said that there was some suggestion that it was a female elf.
[SPEAKER_02]: I assume Khaleesi was still in here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Leave her alone.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do not investigate her at all.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't wish you to go down that path.
[SPEAKER_02]: So don't accost or abduct the guy in the square that sold him the mask, the Scarlet Brotherhood.
[SPEAKER_00]: I told you.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's good information.
[SPEAKER_00]: I will take that on myself.
[SPEAKER_02]: And don't try to track down or bring in...
[SPEAKER_00]: But I assume this...
[SPEAKER_00]: You're trying to turn this thief person?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, and also if we can, find out at least if the thieves guild or at least Janus is taking money from the Toli.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, that's good.
[SPEAKER_02]: We might need more finances in the future, but I try to keep it minimal, five gold initially.
[SPEAKER_00]: How soon do you have to attend to this turncoat?
[SPEAKER_02]: Did you say three days or five days?
[SPEAKER_02]: Three.
[SPEAKER_02]: Three days.
[SPEAKER_02]: I gave him Ferd's bar as a location for an exchange.
[SPEAKER_02]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_02]: He seemed a little bit nervous about using Ferd's bar.
[SPEAKER_02]: He said that he would be killed.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know Ferd's reputation and you know the reputation of that bar.
[SPEAKER_00]: You helped make it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, it's a little disgusting, but it seems safe to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I have killed some people in it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Three days.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you have anything that you want us to follow up on if the assassins, if the totally assassins have left five days ago?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, is that something...
[SPEAKER_00]: I have something actually for you to follow up on that.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's new information to me, and what I would like you to do is go for a boat ride.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, good.
[SPEAKER_02]: I hate water.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where?
[SPEAKER_00]: I am sending a Kosair to Helms Island.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that out by the...
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dragons?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, no, Helms Island is in the Straits.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Monmurg Straits.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would like you to accompany Paul.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul, you'll be on this trip.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gotcha.
[SPEAKER_00]: What would we be doing?
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll be investigating to see if there are any Toli out there.
[SPEAKER_00]: On Helms Island?
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean...
[SPEAKER_00]: This is what the meeting was about.
[SPEAKER_00]: Last night, there was a storm, a strange wind.
[SPEAKER_00]: A fog bank enveloped the entire straits.
[SPEAKER_00]: It lasted several hours.
[SPEAKER_00]: After it dissipated, Helms Island
[SPEAKER_00]: Seemed completely normal.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, our signals to the island during the day, we have not gotten the correct signals back from the helm.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's the fortress that we have out there.
[SPEAKER_00]: They say that everything is fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, we know that's not true.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're not actually giving us the code of the day.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So somebody might have seized the fortress in the unnatural fog.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's possible.
[SPEAKER_02]: Would that be a prelude to a further invasion?
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, who would seize the fortress without planning to do more?
[SPEAKER_02]: How will you have us inserted with the Corsair?
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul Rivero will be himself, and he'll be out there as a...
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean like an open broad daylight that will go to the... You are going to be selling, you will be known with the captain.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know if anybody will blend in at the fortress.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll be there to lend your magical help to this.
[SPEAKER_00]: This could be nothing.
[SPEAKER_00]: To be honest with you, Admiral Fairfield currently is in charge of the helm.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is getting a little older, so I may have given the incorrect order.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, we do need to investigate.
[SPEAKER_02]: Has he ever given the incorrect order up to this point in time?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is it a pretext of the Corsair?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is it just a regular stopover?
[SPEAKER_02]: Or is it a pretext of delivering food or supplies?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you'll be going there in force.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is standard practice, actually.
[SPEAKER_00]: We send warships there all the time.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: But there'll be a full crew.
[SPEAKER_00]: There'll be 250 marines on board.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll be a part of that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Marines?
[SPEAKER_02]: You know, soldiers that fight on the water.
[SPEAKER_02]: Light armor so they can swim.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul, you'll be there to lend the power of Lord Jameis.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, Lord Jeanne.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you understand?
[SPEAKER_00]: You're a representative of Florian in this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Got you.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll be given a writ.
[SPEAKER_00]: What I want you to do is investigate the entire helm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Make sure there are no traitors there.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are no Toli rats there.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are no instigators.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then report to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude, you're with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know what that means.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're to protect him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: When do you want us to leave?
[SPEAKER_00]: As soon as possible.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what the meeting was.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: We are assembling the men right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll leave in two hours.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll leave sooner than that.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll leave within an hour, but get your equipment together.
[SPEAKER_01]: It'll be time.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I get an extra bottle of wine to take with me?
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you cannot do that, Jude.
[SPEAKER_00]: I need you to be sober when you're on the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: You are not royalty.
[SPEAKER_02]: Doesn't seem like they're real quick to own you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Quicker to me than you, that's for sure.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's not saying much.
[SPEAKER_02]: I know my value.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's plenty more just like you.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, really?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't even know what a market is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Apparently, I just need to go down to the market and buy a dark, darker house.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, so... Darker tone.
[SPEAKER_00]: So... You guys are gonna get your shit together.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, you don't have much to get on there.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't have much to get on there.
[SPEAKER_02]: I always carry everything on me.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know about you.
[SPEAKER_02]: You were switching masks, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: What did you come out of this room with?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll come out of my room with a... Alright, so you get ready to go.